the chronic controlled 84th Congress convenes
in Washington with Republican leaders now
authority role and former vice president
alben Barkley back in the Senate where he
served for 22 years heading the Democrats are
senators Clements George Johnson and Hemmings
Vice President Nixon swears in arrogance
Neuberger whose election assured Democratic
Senate control Speaker Martin tell successor Rabin
I would just sound a little weak cautionary note
not to become too attached to this chair next day
President Eisenhower comes before a joint session
of Congress to deliver his State of the Union
message the chief executive entering his third
year in office smilingly acknowledges the warm
ovation from both Republicans and Democrats in
the chamber [ __ ] Rabin rats for silence and the
president expresses thanks President Eisenhower
sums up by saying and so I know in my heart and I
believe that all Americans know that despite the
anxieties of this divided world our faith and the
cause in which we all believe will surely prevail